what's the shortest amount of time
you've written a script
i did a 36 hour
fade in to the end for emmett and furla
films
um project called bad news that i wrote
for them and i did it and i did it on a
tuesday wednesday thursday without sleep
no drugs without sleep and
i crashed thursday at some point
i physically collapsed in my condo and i
woke up at some point friday
printed it out called emmett and
furlough drove it to them
at the warner lot and they optioned it
they called me monday said we love it
it's exactly what we need we want it
that was that was three days non-stop
did the lack of sleep help you get into
a mindset was it some type of a sci-fi
fantasy no no it was an action film it
was i knew the story i wanted to tell
and emmitt and furler were friends we
had done a film or two with them
and they were buying they were working
with people at the time that i worked
with in the past they were working with
avi lerner
and cassian elways and mark rifkin and
some of those guys from the late 90s
that i had worked with that were just
cranking out these
10 to 20 million dollar action movie so
i knew what they wanted
and they were they were optioning
scripts and they were paying to do it
and these guys
i pitched george on it over the phone
and he said oh yeah that sounds cool
give me a script and this was like on
tuesday i hung up the phone it was like
three o'clock in the afternoon i just
started writing
i started writing and i i collapsed at
some point thursday and realized that i
wrote
the end and uh did you wake up
and like the room was spinning or what
happened when did someone find you
[Laughter]
i was living alone at the time it was
after my first uh
my first divorce i was back living alone
uh you know how us bachelors when we
find our way back to bachelorhood
usually live
it was crazy it was just i remember that
time very vividly
and i remember writing it tuesday
afternoon
collapsing at some point thursday and
you know every when you wake up friday
everything's still a blur and i just
remember hitting print there was 96
pages and i just hit print
i punched hold them put a brad in them
called their office to make sure
dow was their guy at the time who was
head of development and i said dallas
shane i'm coming will you give me a pass
he goes yeah yeah yeah we're waiting for
you dude
drove onto the warner lot gave it to
dall and said enjoy and george called me
i think monday or two and said yeah dude
you got a deal this is great
i i will say george has better taste
than that this was 25 years ago
but yeah that was the fastest script i
ever wrote
wow yeah a lot of coffee
oh yeah crown and coffee i don't know
why
crown oil and coffee oh wow i don't know
how an empty stomach
oh wow yeah you got to stay awake wow
and the little purple bag yeah
probably smoked a lot too so i went
through a phase or smoking a lot i think
i probably won't do about 19 packs of
cigarettes that week
good times thank god i'm vegan now i'm
making up you know trying to take care
of myself now that i'm old
that's just quite an image i can i can
almost see it yeah i can tell you
another story similar
okay yeah please i'll tell you another
funny story somewhere we did no code of
conduct
uh for for dimension which was miramax
um
it was a 12 million film we shot we had
a green light on a script charlie sheen
starred in it
and we had written it they didn't want
to tell that story so they had brought
two other writers on a couple of great
guys ed masterson and bill gaqwa
really cool guys we ended up becoming
very good friends for a long time
actually one of them bought a car from
me and
we got to phoenix and the director
and charlie read the script and they go
what the what the hell is this i said i
don't know that's what they sent
you well we start shooting in 48 hours
get your laptop
fade in so we rewrote the script
in arizona two days before we shot
from page one and just about page one
rewrite
that was another all same time of my
life it was within give or take a few
years so i was
still able to do that and how does that
work with the original credit
who cares we're just a bunch of dumb
people making movies you know i mean
they paid
they paid us we were producing the film
they paid the writers it was like they
had to deal with the writers anyway so
those it was like we wrote the film
charlie brett michaels and i wrote the
script and then
they agreed to make the movie we went to
phoenix to make the movie
and then somebody got in the mix and
said that's not the script we want to
make and hired two writers didn't tell
us anything about it and just sent us a
script
the guys never came out to arizona they
were just two guys in la that
were told to rewrite a script that they
weren't happy with
because it was originally written for la
and then they sent us to phoenix for a
tax credit so we get there and
it's just the domino effect you change
the scripts like what the hell is this
this isn't what we
you know charles doesn't know why i'm
here i didn't agree to do this and it
was our company charlie brett and i had
a company so
yeah and they just said come on dynamo
and get some jolt cola or
you know get some coffee and fire it up
let's go and we did it
we did a 48 hour two days before we
wrote
i rewrote the whole script and they i
don't think they ever knew it
so what was what was our 47 like
hour 47 i remember being
in the homestead village they hadn't set
us up in our homes yet they gave us
homes it was a 12 million
film in phoenix in the 90s that's a lot
of money they had us in homestead
village and we each had our own
unit and i remember being in brett's at
his cabinet i probably
i probably smoked three packs of
cigarettes
a day and just drank coffee
it was nuts and then there was a kenny
rogers roasters that that would deliver
right at the end it was like that that
episode of seinfeld
and i was like just living on kenny
rogers roasters for like
two weeks that we were there and his
last 48 hours went through like two
buckets of chicken it was brutal it was
brutal
smelled in there and then i had a day
and a half
and i remember joe lando from dr quinn
was co-starring in it he was our bad guy
and he was a dear friend he still is
and i remember going to my room and
collapsing and you know the sound of a
hotel phone ringing that loud chirp
it woke me up about 18 hours later and
have you ever woken up from asleep so
deep do you feel like you know you got
punched by mike tyson and you just
you're incoherent i remember the phone
ringing
waking up and literally i couldn't see
my eyes were open and i was i was like
mike tyson on his hands and knees when
he got knocked out and he was reaching
remember when he was looking for his
mouthpiece
that was me looking for the phone i
answered it i had the upside down parts
of my ear
i was like hello and joe's like shane
it's joe it's like
yeah and and he to this day he still
makes fun of his way i know the story
and he goes dude
are you okay okay oh yeah and he goes i
think
i caught you is sleeping or something
i'm going to call you back and i
remember it woke me up and i remember i
had to call him back and i couldn't find
him and i was worried something was
wrong
but yeah that's that's what that was
like we started shooting i think the
next morning at 5 00 am
with the script that the three of you
had written yeah and then the director
decided
at 5am he wanted to be in the movie and
he wasn't written in the movie and
turned to me and said why don't you
direct the opening scene i'm going to be
in this
so that was my first directing job
really without getting a job so i shot
the opening scene of no code yeah the
director decided to be in it
you